[Music]
[Music]
feels like I've been walking on
everything going alright
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Thursday it is
an early show for us today as it is our
last show of the week so thank you for
joining us at 9:30 on this particularly
beautiful day in Manhattan it's the
weirdest day it's monsoon season on my
way here it was pouring rain drenched I
couldn't I had raindrops all over me and
then I arrived and it's a beautiful day
in the neighborhood of raindrops all
over isn't that crazy rain drop like
stop pink rain drops you know do you
know him
are you familiar I love the house a
little later than you and it was
literally like I was Tom Hanks mr.
Robinson whatever mr. Rodgers mr.
Rodgers like it's a beautiful day in the
neighborhood
yeah it's really just crazy but it's
beautiful for our show and that's all
that matters
I have to give a two warnings to
everyone watching and listening today I
got my teeth whitened yesterday and I've
been having like chills have sensitivity
in my teeth and if you ever had like a
sensitive moment in your teeth you know
it's naughty I don't even know if it's
pain it's like crippling uncomfort so if
I look weird today like with my face
it's just my teeth and then also if I'm
particularly nasty today it's because I
weighed myself this morning and the
results were just not at all what I
expected
really I was off by about 35 pounds and
I'm very upset and I have to be in a
bathing suit this weekend so if I'm just
coming for everyone like Demi Lovato
singing the national anthem like it's
just it's it's on me it's not on Demi
you know what I'm glad you brought that
up because I was packing for my trip
last night and I literally felt like
such garbage like I no excuse like get
away are you kidding me no I'm not
kidding like I'm not I live with you and
you're fine
but I'm not and it's all about how you
feel and how come you're entitled to
your feelings and no one else's because
my feelings are legitimate but my
feelings are legitimate if I meet you in
a bathing suit and you see me in a
bathing you okay baby but just not the
you seen me in a bathing suit and it's
just like not cute no matter what weight
I'm at so like I just I can't with you I
can't with you and I cannot relate to
like your first world problems okay I
can't really - you're like body
positivity for everyone except for me no
yes
fun because you're not loud if I look
like you oh my god I would do this show
naked every day oh my god that is so
kind of you to say but like I just want
you to know that's not how it feels and
if you if you were me and
felt like me you would not you want to
know why we're not equal because you
didn't just say that back to me if I
were you I would do this show take I
would but I'm I'm a never-nude
I wouldn't do anything naked we're not
equal you guys so we are not we are so
yes that's why I'm in a bad mood
it's Demi Lovato being a national anthem
the story today sure
is it yet is okay because I have
thoughts in if it wasn't I would dive in
but honestly the stories today are
really random there's one that's
particularly random but I chose it for
you because I look forward to hearing
your thoughts ooh spooky
very very spooky stuff um we should jump
right in just because I know you have
fights to catch not feelings but I had
dinner with a very prestigious podcast
host last night
this natcher yeah it was amazing to like
bogged down like 15 minutes with her she
was you know in and out with her glass
of wine Oh Waze is in and out she's
scheduled like to the minute no I know
and it was like I felt really honored
that she even like came out town to have
dinner with me like near my house and it
was just really amazing to like see
people doing amazing things like I hope
one day my show can be a bit as big as
hers no I hope so too and I just hope I
could be the snatchler one day but I
guess I ready I'm according to you I
have a lot to complain about anything
ever
yeah you're allowed to complain but you
are that's natural so like just listen I
really appreciate you saying that but
like it's whatever I don't want to go
into it anyways I have my book club last
night and the first monthly book club
because we chose the book last month I
know I've been talking about book club
for a while but finally the book club it
was the dinner book club so every week
we choose a new restaurant that people
every month sorry we choose a new
restaurant that people want to go to and
a book and it was so much fun
what was the restaurant khaimah which I
actually had been to I thought that I
had and it's a Greek restaurant in
Flatiron food was so good the company
was so good I don't know who I thought
was going to this book club but it was
just six people and I didn't like an
all-call gay people we just had like
such a fun time and I just feel like
this is the start of something
incredible and if you've been on the
fence about like starting a book club
with your friends I just want to say
take the plunge like I could start a
book club but I just like wouldn't want
to read you know I'd be there for like
the food and the energy but not really
the literature yeah and I feel like you
could say okay we'll do a dinner every
you know third Wednesday of the month
but like you need a little bit more
structure than that otherwise it's like
why are we sticking to this Oh 1,000%
like I'm supposed to have dinner with my
friends like once every two weeks so we
never go so they'd be able to like a TV
club like we'll start a series oh that's
cute yeah Maura
for me yeah and now it's like if we've
read like someone will choose a book and
if everyone's ready yeah like I want to
get together and discuss it I did the
reading and it's the best feeling I
wouldn't know the feeling until last
night when you do the reading and you
have the answers to the
thought-provoking question what were
some of the questions that people were
talking about they were good questions
so um the book was called conviction by
denise Mira and it's from the hello
sunshine list and one of the questions
was the film rights have been acquired
for this book who would you see as
playing with the questions there they
were online like a lot of Oh like on
Kindle and stuff have the
thought-provoking questions after so I
was like who would you like to see
playing the characters um which
character did you like most but I
thought a lot of them were we're not
very relatable I would like to see rebel
Wilson in the film and it was just it
was interesting but everyone agreed had
the same thoughts about me as the book
is like the first half was so great and
compelling and the second half was
written by someone else I'm so glad you
guys were all on the same page it was
just really fun but then I didn't get
home until 10:00 and I had to pack and I
was just wiped yeah overwhelmed Jack and
I are both going to Mexico separately
this weekend which is such a weird
coincidence for a couple girls who like
never really go to Mexico know it's such
a weird coincidence I guess it's like a
big weekend in Mexico I think the
weirder part of the whole thing is that
the places that we're going in Mexico
are both on the west coast so we both
have to take connecting flights and on
our way home our connecting flight like
we'll be landing in New York together
we're on the same second leg which is
funny we did it on purpose once I saw
that that was an option for you I was
like we have to be on the scene right
but like cwienke dink so random so
random alright we jump in should we is
it time I don't know what time is
because it's like it feels like daylight
savings because we're an hour early you
know and by the way there's so much more
traffic an hour earlier in the city is
there so much more took me double the
time interesante well without further
ado it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast YUM
and I'm really excited to take a bite
out of my morning toast but what is what
is toast if you're eating it alone
that's why today's episode is brought to
you by OkCupid I've never been on a date
where you just had nothing in common
with the person a lot of people don't
know this but OkCupid has really changed
at the dating game by asking you tons of
questions about yourself
and what type of person you're looking
for they go pass a standard like dating
app questions like what's your favorite
color they go more in depth on some of
our favorite questions that we've seen
on there are are you a morning person do
you make new year's resolutions very
important says a lot about a person
could you date someone that couldn't be
bothered to vote I just think like the
more in-depth you get like they save you
time they're not wasting your time
sending you on dates with people you
have absolutely no nothing in common
with they get more in depth with the
questions which in turn and gets you
better results um okay Cuban totally
works I have heard from many toasters
that they have like full relationships
kids with people they met on OkCupid
which i think is amazing it's the most
mentioned dating app in the new york
times wedding section which is just a
very interesting factoid stop the
mindless time on dating apps and go to
the app where you choose what matters
OkCupid is totally free so we don't even
have to give you a very long code or a
website just download it OkCupid in the
app store today go on a great date this
week and then tell us about that great
person you met we will definitely come
to the wedding I said this last week if
some toaster downloads OkCupid for my
recommendation meets the love of their
life and has gets engaged I will be at
the wedding I will ordain perform
officiate and sing a song I think that's
a great and very fair deal and I think
like who needs like what better
motivation to get started on OkCupid
than that and to sign on and find love
love that for you okay
also people are commenting on my
spectrum it is that's really cool Jesus
is king it's really cool it doesn't look
cute on the stream I'm seeing but I
finally got it like months after
ordering it cuz I guess he jus made to
order
he doesn't each order and he must get
like so many orders that were I don't
know but it took truely months but you
know what like there's no time like the
present I was happy to get it yeah I
don't really mind like when I bought in
Ariana Grande like even though I'm not a
such a huge fan but I really liked this
tie-dye sweatshirt that said God it's a
woman took like literally a year to come
and as I could escape checking to make
sure it was still in transit like I
wasn't bothered by the fact that it took
so long I just want to make sure it
wasn't not coming right I honestly
completely forgot about this until I got
a shipment saying an email saying that
it was shipped and it was just exciting
it was like I shopped for myself who's
like a surprise from me to me right kind
of Birchbox this isn't that but yeah and
speaking of ads my shoes are Rafi's and
I just want to share that with the class
because they're the most comfortable
shoes I've ever worn we did a read for
them last week and I look forward to
traveling in them it's not a show
they're so come
and three slip on slip off since I know
you don't have TSA PreCheck no I don't I
can't believe you we're like such a
you're a really very cosmopolitan gal I
just don't think I travel that much like
I travel when I travel but I'm not a
huge traveler you're not a huge traveler
but I definitely think you travel more
than the average American I guess I
don't know I just don't really see the
need before Jeff can and if you have
clear no I'm flying out of LG and you've
clear you're in the clear yeah I'm
flying out of LJ and most of the time
I'm on time so it's like okay if I've to
wait 15 minutes in a line like so be it
the airport sucks anyway where am I
going
I just sit at my gate I find it shocking
that you wouldn't have a huge problem
with the taking off of the shoes putting
your bare feet on the flo
it always is weird yeah it's a weird
feeling you're such a germy I know but
when I'm having a travel day like I'm
like sure I'm a big germ anyway so
what's the difference
Tigra okay first story a little breakup
news because Kaia Gerber and Pete
Davidson have reportedly split and she's
focusing on her modeling I think really
need like an official statement from
their publicist because if this had just
fizzled out like on one of the million
girls that Pete Davidson dates like it
would have been fine so this seems
really formal to me yeah I think it's
really interesting and at this point
it's like Pete Davidson really doesn't
care about people thing because I would
feel like he would stay in these
relationships longer just to prove
something but you know he like doesn't
care if this is his rap and that's
something a woman would do like men
don't care it's cool if you date a lot
of models like you're then like a John
Mayer loves dating models like Kurt
George Clooney like dinner ruin their
lives no I don't think it's gonna ruin
anyone's lives but then it's like the
next relationship and also like the
girls like at a certain point yes what
girl would want to date P Davidson if
she know she's just gonna get her heart
broken
no and I totally get a girl like in
Andie McDowell's daughter what was her
name Margaret Rainey no that's another
sister Margaret quale yeah I understand
a girl like that dating Pete Davidson
but a girl like Kyogre burr knowing she
might just be like one in a million
models like she doesn't mean you know
what I mean yeah but then it all goes
back a lesser-known girl it all goes
back to the bde though it's like I mean
Kaia Gerber needs some media and maybe
they just liked him like there's some
great personality there it is something
about Pete yeah there is there and I
think we've all established out like
that Kate Beckinsale would join this
club such a prominent woman she's so
like everything like she survived Pearl
Harbor totally for this to be with Pete
Davidson at a hockey game we're gonna
grande of course
she was like one first so she didn't
know about the pattern she has
Christopher Columbus discovering
discover me Ramon discover me Kathy
David yes yes but he was still very
unknown while dating Cassidy and Carly
Aquilino oh I'm sorry thank you so much
for bringing that up
absolute justice for Carly Aquilino
comedian from girl code
she dated Pete Davidson first when he
was an actual nobody and then I think
CAHSEE was right after that I totally
forgot that she was the penis has been
going on for a really long time and I
know we're just seeing it now because
like the girls are starting to look more
and more like but just like this chain
of events of like girl after girl and
it's like premium girl after premium
girl has been going on for a while
Cassie David seems to be the prototype
in terms of looks because after her
everyone except for Ariana everyone
looks the same Harlequin Lena was a
redhead she's very you vibe like pale
skin so maybe maybe he's got a different
taste and like the Cassie David's of the
world best he knows what he likes now
yeah everybody what to say who do you
think he'll date next given that we know
his type honestly like Rooney Mara like
that's the vibe no the craziest thing in
the world is that Rooney Mara and
Phoenix are madly and loved and perfect
for each other you're perfect for each
other like I imagine the inside of their
house is a dump like they're just like
so creative like they can't bother to
flush the toilet like I feel like they
double-date with crimes and Elon Musk
and in another world like Grimes and
Joaquin Phoenix really glad to be
together I didn't really matter anymore
I must work there too at this point
they're just like interchangeable human
beings but I actually think it's really
cute and I think the weirdest thing is
that rooney mara and kate mara our
sisters yes and i think they come from
like a really wealthy fair that like
owns the Jets right yeah okay if we both
think it actually then we probably told
each other and we're both going off the
same false news kate mara and routine
are like have totally different careers
they look so different like I never
would have pictured them being sisters
and then it's like this thing about
Kiera is so crazy is that she was pushed
in front of a train by Kevin Spacey and
like justice for her because it never
came to life you are kate mara and i am
earning totally you know nearly a skinny
artistic and create it and like dark and
dirty and you're just like beautiful and
like you just met the love of your life
at work who is she with she is with that
guy Jamie he's like not even cute is he
the one who used to date Keira Knightley
maybe he's like one of those British
types but alas sir
they were still dating but she's so like
a relevant that they could have broken
up but I wouldn't have known but they
like met on a movie set that got
nominated for a bunch of awards they did
the award season together and then they
just lie quietly like went to a chateau
in England is so cute that's like Grammy
Malik Lucy Boyton whoo yeah just shaping
up to be a little eccentric the fakest
couple ever lay so convenient for luck
they were there was so much Oscar buzz
around them they had that weird like
Bryan Singer thing but they then this
eclipsed that and I totally thought it
was like a Rob Pattinson Kristen Stewart
like arranged but they kind of liked
each other and now I think maybe they
just actually fell in love okay for the
record Rob Pattinson and Kristen Stewart
were true love he said that but there
was definitely some coercion and getting
them together but it didn't matter
because they were so in love you can't
you can't act chemistry like that no you
can't and what makes the Twilight series
so incredible despite the fact that you
think it would just be like a cheesy
vampire trilogy is the fact that they
are just like so caught up ahead chowder
is so happy boy like you can feel it you
can see it like no one even Kristen
Stewart is that good of an actress like
she really felt that way about Rob like
she felt like intimidated by him and
like he wanted to protect her like
obviously like the vampire was kind of
like this symbolism for fame if you
think about it you know like Rob had it
and you want to keep Kristen you know
safe yeah that's beautiful
very beautiful okay you ready for our
next story that's just made for you what
a juror who's wife starred on Weinstein
produced Project Runway has been
dismissed wait you're never gonna guess
it but a germ an okay whose wife was on
Project Runway which was produced by
Harvey Weinstein okay I had to be
dismissed from the case the husband of
TV personality Zanna Roberts Rassi Oh
was dismissed as a prospective juror
Zanna Roberts Rassi
oh she was on his a like a ghost like a
judge I have no clue but you know her
husband is he should be dismissed for
other reasons he's a trillionaire Wow
someone just made the best comment I've
ever seen
about you know someone should start a
sock company called OTP two pair of
socks very random but Danny Roberts
Rassi husband if I'm correct is the
founder of milk makeup uh he's very well
oh yes he he is with his wife and
partners they found in milk make oh I'm
sure that he has
like he's a billionaire I'm sure he's
actually met Harvey Weinstein like
that's gotta be the only reason he said
no he said I know Harvey and his family
and his wife and children and then when
he asked when the judge asked if he
could be like a fair and impartial juror
he said I don't think I can no you can't
know someone's kids and be an impartial
juror no no definitely not and also like
if you were running a big company like
that I don't think you can get like
caught up in a trial like this like you
have places to go I just don't
understand how like you know millions of
trials happen every year and like no
celebrities are finding themselves
caught up in it but now we have two
major like stars only in New York only
in New York and only around Harvey
Weinstein this seems like plant it's so
weird no I guess it's just like but
those are the odds like there are so
many interesting people that live in New
York yeah if you're getting like a
hundred and twenty people on one day the
odds that two of them are people that
we've heard of and it's not like this
guy is famous because God and his wife
is semi famous so it's just like he is
in the industry and New York you know
it's very much a big part of the media
industry so it's it's only makes sense
that these people have crossed paths I
mean in New York it's kind of the
epicenter for everything I heard they
film the morning toast there Oh first
sure I heard they actually just got this
like sickness to do yeah very sick also
gigi hadid is going back to the
courthouse today to continue the jury
duty you know questionnaire did you see
how many paparazzi were waiting for
outside no Julie had one bodyguard and
like it honestly wasn't enough he does a
great job like he was really just being
like she just said I can't comment on
the trial I can't come out on the trial
like people were just throwing questions
she said I can't comment on the trial I
can't comment on the trial and he was
pushing people on the way like she
literally couldn't even get to the car
it was so crazy that is so crazy also
Harvey Weinstein I read is trying to get
the trial moved out of New York I don't
know like why he thinks that that would
help him like why he thinks he's special
now well ya know nothing's really gonna
help him no and I don't see people in
New York are [ __ ] brutal like it's if
he can't get a jury of your peers
brutality yeah if you can't get
acquitted here he can't get acquitted
anywhere yeah I think this is great I'm
very much looking forward to justice
being served very much and I'm very much
looking forward to meeting these suitors
I doubt you yedid will be one of them
but you know what crazier things have
happened
yeah in this world I don't want to ruin
your day like gjd dating Tyler see to me
is crazier than her being on the hunter
jury selection for Harvey wines on the
one ruin your day but I think you had
some spray tan on your oh these no no
say it in so I don't see it where like
literally right there I don't see it
stop okay so harshing my mellow sorry
I'm sorry
there's no Jesus just dismissed so I
guess breaking news crazy things aren't
happening today it wouldn't be okay they
wouldn't be fair it wouldn't be fair and
not that I think he'd like to serves a
fair trial but everyone does and like
you said yesterday you made an excellent
point that he could start claiming
mistrial right look I know Gigi she's
not impartial yeah
she started one of my movies like
something like that you know yeah I
didn't give her the part so right right
right right right
you know yeah just start making [ __ ] up
so I think it's better I think she
should have recused herself but I
understand why she didn't but she
probably did think that she could be
fair and impartial but it's just like
this is too close to home I just know
myself like I wouldn't I'm the worst
possible candidate for jury duty like I
could never be impartial like if you're
on trial like you did it you know like
if you made your way like into this
courtroom like there's something wrong
if it wasn't this it was something else
you should read the book which you'll
never do and you'll never watch the
black at night movie but 12 Angry Men no
but I saw heavy Angry Men inside Amy
Schumer
have you ever heard of the book of
course that's how I know how many people
are on a jury okay but like do you know
what happens how much to me someone's
falsely accused know what it's like
they are 12 Angry Men they're sitting on
the jury and they all completely believe
that um the man doeth the man did it and
they were about to turn in the verdict I
might be like totally about tching this
story or thinking of something else
and but then one juror was like let's
just like think about how this story has
holes in it and like maybe figure out if
he didn't do it and like they totally
figured out that it wasn't him when they
were about to just turn into goodbye the
verdict that was just a joke like a
little bit maybe I'll turn into like a
comedy sketch obviously know that like
if you're in court you didn't do it I'm
just saying I was making a joke
don't cut for me please okay it's okay
he's obviously joke like honestly it's
early I think people are too tired to
come
but if you are today's episode is all -
you also brought to you by REM rise but
you might not be watching because you
bought memorize the last time we spoke
about it and you're still peacefully
asleep some people have trouble falling
asleep some people have trouble staying
asleep and some people have trouble with
both I definitely one of the people who
have trouble falling asleep once I'm out
I'm out like a light and the words of
Drake but falling asleep is super hard
for me on average people are getting
less quality of sleep more than ever
tackling sleep issues shouldn't feel
impossible but existing sleep aids
aren't effective and they make you
groggy in the morning very true I've
tried it all that's why there's REM rise
it's a personalized sleep solution
uses natural plant-based formulas to
help calm the mind relax the body and
get your circadian rhythm back on track
for a better more sort of sleep it's a
drug free it's drug free with no groggy
side-effects in the morning all you have
to do is go to get REM rice calm / toast
and take their free sleep quiz we took
the quiz it actually makes you feel
really seen and asks you questions you
might not think about when it comes to
sleep they come also but they have a
digital app that you can use to track
your sleep progress and they even have
guided meditation to help you get in the
right mindset do what we did check out
REM rise today go to get REM rise calm /
toast
take their sleep quiz and when you sign
up you'll get your first week of REM
rise free just pay for the shipping but
you have to use our link get REM our ISE
calm / toast you won't find an offer
like this anywhere else ok your first
week of excuse me REM rise for free when
you sign up at get REM rise calm / toast
again that offer is get REM rise calm /
toast for your first week of REM rise
free sign on sleep well really so
important sleep is just like the most
beautiful thing in the world to me like
the most precious gift bestowed on us
from God I couldn't agree more
and you must do everything to procure
it's sanctity fiber and REM rise is one
of those things that just is a game
changer I'm on like a really good sleep
week where I have now slept for every
day this week in 9 hours oh wow I'm in a
really good sleep week where I woke up
each morning I woke I had to wake up
earlier than usual every day Jim and I
didn't wake up feeling like a beast
which is really weird and you know what
I think it's because I've been reading
more and I've just been sleeping better
because I think the TV is like [ __ ]
I'm right did you watch bosses in New
Jersey no because you know what I like
God home I was like I have to pack in
Montreal Housewives of New Jersey I
packed it was 12 o'clock and I just went
white right to sleep I didn't realize I
forgot until the morning that's never
happening it putting sleep first I'm not
angry and we won't recap it then but let
me just tell you something that happened
cool so they all went to Jackie's house
in the Hamptons I didn't know Jackie had
a house in Westhampton
and they're all talking about like a
couple weeks ago Jackie tweeted like
there's a rumor that I'm the richest
housewife and like literally nobody said
that girl and she was like it's
definitely not true and it's like don't
worry we never thought that but she has
a house in Westhampton Beach and it's
super nice it's not the house of the
it's not the house of the richest
possible housewife ever but it's super
nice and Jennifer she was sitting with
Bill her husband who like I just loved
their scenes together
and oh the husband's go to the Hampton
you know they were packing oh oh and she
texted Jackie was like can I have the
address and because they were like
taking a car the next day and she
googled the house like pictures how much
a rent for how much she bought it for
comps in the area which is like so
something I would do so like I just
loved her and also it was really like a
jennifer episode it was super boring but
they had a very open conversation with
about her mom about the brother and the
mother got all choked up and the mom was
just like I'm just so old-fashioned like
she wasn't being like hateful she was
just like really having a hard time
understanding she was like all I want is
for him to be happy and I felt like we
took a big step in the right direction
and I really had a Jennifer I'm excited
too I'm putting that on blast because
like putting making your family
uncomfortable on TV like it's definitely
afterwards but I think it was for a good
cause
mm-hmm so what's the deal with the house
it was super nice it's a beach house
it's on the beach in West Hampton so
like definitely millions um it's it's
nice it's really is it her house with
her husband or so then next week we had
a preview where because also she said
something really weird in this episode
when they had that Mother's Day brunch
they were just talking about like what
they were all like his kids and Jack he
was like my mom's did the funniest thing
like I was dating someone before Evan
and like I knew he really wanted to
marry me but I was not into it and he
bought a ring and my mom bought the ring
off of him and said when when you guys
are ready to get engaged buy it back for
me so it's it's kept safe I mean they
were like how much was it and she was
like 15 grand so then like then that's
when Jennifer was like all high like her
antennas went up about Jackie's finances
and then I think next week they have a
conversation about it
because Jackie says she comes from
family money okay yeah very interesting
I look forward to that playing out yeah
it was an interesting conversation and
I'm gonna watch it but I downloaded two
books for the plane garage and I nice
book I'm so excited because my friend
Britt from book club last night said it
was the funniest book she ever read I
have a copy if you want it well now I
have my Kindle and it's a life-changing
device it is and I think it's also a
life-saving device like it should be a
medical equipment for sure because like
I'm sleeping better I'm living better
I'm more educated more educated than
ever more educated than ever
okay next story as requested by you but
I also chose it because I just I'm
obsessed I mean yeah Demi Lovato will
sing the national anthem at the 2020
Super Bowl in Miami yes yes yes dear
pink no that was the year before who
sang it last year we weren't there so we
wouldn't really know yeah I mean usually
there was the Super Bowl last year
Oh Atlanta oh yeah you
they'll tap someone I was like a test
for halftime show like Lady gaga did it
I think twice and then got halftime show
um I don't think that you're not getting
rest in I don't think this means
anything for Demi Lovato as it pertains
to her potentially being the halftime
show because she's not nearly at the
level that she would need to be at to be
a halftime feel but we're getting a new
album from her this year but she's still
super young like I don't think she's
gonna do it before I mean we know Taylor
Swift probably won't ever get to do it
but it's not a youth thing it's just a
catalog and like prestige things like
Demi Lovato was not even close no but
because she doesn't have the catalog yet
because she's very young but there are
people her age like ariana grande I
could do it
Taylor Schmidt's could do it Taylor
Swift could do it Taylor Swift's older
than her um but I'm saying she could do
it at some point
yeah I'm just feeling salty I don't I
mean actually I think she's a great
voice but to me it's just like she's
been irrelevant for so long she's the
perfect person to sing the national
anthem I guess oh my big person I'm so
excited to hear her rendition like when
it comes to the national anthem I don't
care about the album's that you put out
I don't care about your singles I care
about your voice and Demi Lovato is the
voice right because if it was about like
albums like we get Selena Gomez to do it
and homegirl can't even sing by the way
second album so it's so no we put in it
was she's super relevant like that's
what I mean like she was an album and
she's like promoting something I want to
hear SIA sing the national anthem
totally good to see a halftime show I
would love that and the Kelly Clarkson
show please Kelly Clarkson show I mean
JLo is a great slack she's a true
performer oh I'm so excited
and we have so excited when we went to
the Super Bowl two years ago there was a
huge DirecTV party held at a stadium and
in this huge box in the stadium was like
this VIP party but at the stadium was a
JLo concert and it was literally a JLo
halftime show it was everyone with in
town for JLo yeah it was just as big of
a deal as a Super Bowl and I think that
was probably like a test run for her to
do the Super Bowl cuz she was [ __ ]
amazing
yeah and I know her like her vocals are
fine but it's really like the
performance of it all it's like the
dancing the singing the moon she's a
triple threat she the outfits like
acting yeah she really is a triple
threat so I'm not looking for like the
most amazing vocals for her but that's
not really what you're looking for and
halftime perform yeah I'm looking to be
razzle dazzled Wow yeah razzle dazzle me
and I'm so glad that they are out of the
trend of doing like multiple people like
when I was Bruno Mars
JLo and Shakira Oh
they're not out of the trance okay I'm
excited to see it yeah i think mr time
is that it just a dream I think that was
a dream of a lot of people I think maybe
he is I haven't seen Shakira before I'm
in a minute so I totally forgot like
even what she looks like
so that'll be interesting I'm so glad
it's night saying last year and she did
a great job yeah that's why I don't
remember yeah okay well I'm so excited
super bowl is just sneaking up on us you
guys he's sneaky are we going I don't
know maybe I guess you could just go
like no one has to invite us it'll be a
game time decision huh yeah no and I
don't even want to go to the game I just
wanna go to the parties no but if we're
in town I want to go to the game we had
the best day of our lives at the Super
Bowl and then I was so hungover yeah
yeah that was fun that was fun it was
good times good times
it was great times it's cool to be like
I mean the traffic's annoying but it's
cool to be like in a big cultural moment
like yeah I think we only look back on
the Super Bowl as being so much fun
because it was actually two weeks before
we got canceled so it was like the last
great thing we did yes totally and we
were at the peak of our lives at that
point right and the live show we did on
the red carpet of the wheels up party
was one of the funniest things ever some
of the funniest [ __ ] we've ever done in
our lives
yeah we need to start doing more and I'm
like red carpet pop-ups yeah that was
hardly a red carpet it was just like a
slab of concrete was a plane hangar a
hangar party yeah but there was some
cool people who didn't talk to us but
Josh almond made us take a picture of
him never forgot there were some cool
beeps there who walked by us yeah it was
cool to be near them Oh Jalen a rod
walked right behind us oh yes very
exciting interview we got with their
backs yeah that's you Jess okay next
story peacock NBC's new streaming
service is debuting soon it won't have
baby Yoda but it will have ads
interesante Apple show yeah
Apple showed up to the streaming wars
with Jennifer Aniston and Reese
Witherspoon Disney arrived with baby
Yoda and the event or any Avengers HBO
max is bringing friends and now it's
Comcast's turn and the cable and TV
giant thinks it can get a leg up on its
rivals by offering something very
different free video plus ads okay so
you don't have to pay for it oh yeah ads
I'm fine with that I'm fine with that
too yeah that rocks that's better for me
because like the subscription is a
commitment like I subscribe to a plus I
have a few more episodes of a morning
show laughs but I can't cancel my
subscription until I finish the episodes
that I'm not ready
ya know I think this is brilliant it's
kind of how Julio has like different
options premium commercial free you can
watch with commercials I think that's
like kind of genius yeah it's not
exactly how Comcast NBC Universal group
is going to position it to the peacock
service which will unveil Thursday and
roll out in April like rival services
peacock will boast a mix of old TV
movies and TV shows including the office
and some new stuff including a
Battlestar Galactica reboot it may also
offer bells and whistles like sneak
peeks of Jimmy Fallon's Tonight Show a
new NBC News service and a big dose of
the 2020 Olympics oh right they totally
are gonna like win so many customers
just because like you could stream the
Olympics on your phone or something no
and also because of the office like
that's it's like friends for HBO max yes
yeah so when it comes to the streaming
like landscape the streaming wars I I
now I'm on Disney Plus but only that
because Olivia like got us a free year
with Verizon or something like she set
it up so I have it but I don't think I
would ever pay out of pocket for it I
will be paying out of pocket for HBO Max
and I think I will become one of those
ads subscribers for a peacock yeah that
way I can have like now like five
streaming services as a cord cutter um I
feel as though I really participate in
all of these these were all made for me
because I don't pay for cable I can pay
for like even if you add up the cost of
all streaming Netflix Hulu uh Apple plus
etc it's still less than paying for
cable you are like the quintessential
millennial millennial who like this
streaming war is about your antennas are
like retrieving information you're like
the typical person who all these
different streaming like articles should
be about um so I would just love to hear
what you think about it you know um I
feel really good about it like we've
said competition is great for the
consumer and in this is it's like we're
just getting premium content on top of
premium content yet I can't find
anything to watch and all they're doing
is reading you know I can't find
anything to watch and then once I do I
like savor it's so hard like I have
saved the last five episodes I have a
Mazal for the plane
I want to rewatch cheer like and every
time I finish something really good I'm
like in a lull until I find the next
thing and I've been in a major lull
since I finished Desperate Housewives
over a year ago Wow speaking of cheer
though Jerry is on cameo and I just like
want to support everything that he's
doing I got a cameo for the scenes he's
working on his Matt talk on cameo and
it's just premium and I just like the
size for him we're trying to support him
in so many ways like financially Jack
and I both donated 150 dollars to
his GoFundMe then we just gave him $50
on cameo but like it's so cameo it was
made for him oh and he's still cheering
so I just wanted to contribute to his
cheering expenses yeah it's expensive to
be a cheerleader that's what I learned
from cheer on Netflix
very true are you still in a lull and is
there something that you want to share
about that I am still in a lull but you
know what's really helping me talk space
ever feel like New Year's just reminds
you of everything you didn't do the year
before we all have habits we want to
kick in 2020 but you don't have to set
unrealistic goals to make a positive
change without support goals can feel
impossible no wonder why only 8% of
Americans stick with New Year's
resolutions there's no one-size-fits-all
way to meet your goals want a
sustainable way to make lasting change
try talk space the most convenient an
affordable way to get the support of a
licensed therapist match with one of
over 5,000 therapists based on your
preferences from the privacy of your own
device start messaging with your
therapist the very same day be a text
audio picture or video your therapist
will provide ongoing guidance and
support so you can see concrete change
at your own pace it feels like a
personal trainer for your life and you
never need to go to an office or
schedule an appointment so I don't know
if I ever told you this memory Mia Marga
we're talking about how we like Loki
wants to start therapy mm-hmm so I asked
my recommendation and like it's actually
really hard to like find a therapist say
you're comfortable with like do you want
a man or a woman and I want to like one
session and it was it was nice but I
just like couldn't find myself like
getting up every day and like physically
going and like paying for it it just it
seemed like it was a good idea but just
like good idea poor execution but then
when talks are easy for me when talk
space started sponsoring the toast I
thought it was a great way to like a
great middle ground for me and I've
actually really enjoyed it and you get
real lasting change and it's all about
small sustainable shifts over time their
online therapy makes getting the
accountability of a licensed therapist
is easy and most importantly more
affordable they match you with one of
over 5,000 licensed therapists and you
can start messaging with your therapist
on day one reach them anywhere anytime
all from the privacy of your own phone
or computer you'll have a dedicated
support system you need to achieve your
goals one step at a time
it's the perfect way to find a licensed
therapist and start start 2020 off right
with talk space it's a support you need
to help achieve your goals at a price
you can afford and you can get $100 off
your first month when you use the code
toast when you sign up don't wait for
another year to go by no matter what
2019 was like set yourself up for
success in 2020
match with the perfect therapist today
at talk space calm or download the
mobile app and don't forget to use code
toast $400 off your first month that's
talk space.com promo code toast check it
out sign on get a space for your head um
also just about comcast there will also
offer tears for peacock so you can pay
for it to not have bad right um but this
is just something they're doing to
differentiate themselves from the rest
in them you're for it I hope they do
like really fun you know like Bravo's
only always doing commercials like with
Bravo Liberty's for like random movies I
hope they do like streaming service
commercials like with Britney and Jax
you know oh for sure it's funny like of
them like watching something with
Kenneth the page yes I mean I really
hope they lean into 30 rock culture no
because they're not gonna be on a
peacock because then I just I have to
pay for the whole thing for sure it will
be but I need Kenneth the page to
describe like what's so great about
peacock and working for NBC and why I
should be I'm peacock and not the other
streaming of TV and how it's important I
[ __ ] love can't it's the page already
rock is one of the best shows I haven't
rewatched it in a while I think maybe
it's just time uh eighties time also for
the best story I've ever clicked on in
my life and I know it's gonna be so like
so huge for you Spotify has launched a
playlist for dogs left home alone oh my
god Spotify has made playlists and a
podcast for dogs to listen to in their
owners absence after finding that nearly
74 percent of UK pet owners play music
for their animals
the Swedish audio streaming business
company said it launched a podcast
featuring soothing music dog directed
praise stories and messages of
affirmation and reassurance narrated by
actors to alleviate stress for dogs who
are home alone
oh my god meanwhile playlists aimed at
pets offer tracks selected by algorithms
to match pets characteristics such as
energetic or slow Spotify said it found
in a survey that one in for pet owners
play music for their pets to listen to
for company when they are away from home
with 42% of owners saying their pets
have a favorite type of music
CEO loves friends Wow this is genius I
mean there's so much guilt when you're a
dog mom like just closing the door and
like you close close close you just see
their little face begin out like it's
it's so depressing and you just want to
do everything you can for them and at
some point like you're only able to do
so much for your dog until you have to
go to work like
you know and that's just unavoidable and
a lot of offices are becoming dog
friendly which i think is amazing but
for the majority of Americans that is
not the case so I think that this is
really a brilliant I love the playlist
for dogs every time I'm babysitting my
nephew Sameach s I always look for
content like on YouTube like music for
dogs
TV for dogs dog TV and he's never into
it so I'm really excited for like
Spotify to use their scientists which
like have worked there Sciences on me
like I'm getting me to find music that
they know that I'll love like I know
that they'll tap into the dog mind and
that this is just gonna change Theo's
life and also a podcast for dogs
brilliant the morning the morning bark I
mean there's no like I don't I'm
assuming that these playlists and songs
aren't meant to like make them you know
excited they're meant to just make them
feel like they're less alone because I
think like a dogs biggest fear is being
a little bit and that's what podcasts
are meant to do like yeah we are here to
make you feel less alone in this world
and just to help you get through the day
until your owner comes home yes your
husband or whatever like not that your
husband's your owner that was also a
joke no until your boss calls you into a
meeting totally that is so like genius
Spotify is like really just like
surpassing every other music streaming
surpassing like since the day it stepped
on to the Seas inception it's incredible
it's like I was listening Spotify on my
TV it's just like it really knows me
better than I know myself and then like
making everyone feels left out who
doesn't have Spotify with their end of
your date like that's just brilliant
brilliant and like yes take my data use
it sell it to advertisers do what you
have to do but also give it back to me
and teach me about myself and let me
know what I've been up to this year and
what my favorite songs were thank you
very much so did you downloaded the TV
show sue the plane um I did but I also
downloaded two books
Rebecca said her favorite book ever is
called I am pilgrim so I was like I want
it I want to know what someone else's
favorite book is boring as [ __ ] I know
but it's about a book it's not about a
pilgrim oh okay um my favorite book ever
I don't know but my favorite broke up
like the last twelve that I've read um I
did I just read what else forgot and
overall I liked it because I liked the
premise of it um but I just loved so if
he can tell it like can you keep a
secret and I owe you one
and the shopaholic series are my
favorite series of all time yeah I tried
to be a reader but it turns out I'm
nothing of the sort
it's okay it's not for everyone you know
Jackie and I need like really come to UM
I mean I heard that New York yes I have
but something that we do I mean you
watch the show every day you know that
we do it it's like we say one thing and
then like that's like when we were
saying it's pretty cool yeah and then
all I speak I was saying I love that for
you like who also like the [ __ ] out of
my face so right and then now just I've
been feeling like I've been talking
about people and then I'm like she
thinks she's something but she's nothing
of the sort she is nothing like that if
you've ever seen Tiffany New York
Pollard was on Big Brother UK she got to
an enormous fight with this girl Gemma
and then I think Gemma left did they
asked her like how she felt about Gemma
and she it was quite possibly the
meanest [ __ ] like rant you could ever
say about with someone basically saying
that somebody lied to this girl Chapman
told her she was like beautiful and hot
and sexy and it turns out that she's
nothing of this sort and she's nothing
like she thinks she is and she has a
pair of shoes that she said are made for
beautiful women and if that's the case
that she should return those shoes and
put them back on the shelf because Gemma
is nothing of the sort
and it's just the shadiest and it's one
of the most iconic moments in reality
television and I'm really like I like
pizzette like I'm really a simile what's
the word like integrating it into my
vernacular yes so am I oh and she thinks
that she possesses a vernacular that she
does not possess it's just so funny and
so now we're just using bits and pieces
all the time yeah and she is nothing of
the sort
so I know nothing of the sort I know you
didn't watch real houses in New Jersey
so I'm gonna give you a little quick
recap for the people that did watch it
brought to you of course by Robin Hood
the 2020 is a perfect time to start
thinking about 2014 with Robin Hood you
can best in the markets and earn
interest with a competitive APY on
uninvested cash they make it easy to get
started and learn as you grow out with
an intuitive app experience and no
Commission on fees and trades I just
want to say I've been on Robin Hood
since um actually before they started
sponsoring the choice because you know
who told me about it
TPG we were out to dinner and he told me
you just I was asking it I'm like you're
so rich like how visa rich and he was
like well I invest a lot and I'm like
it's not super intimidating and he just
literally pulled out his phone and
showed me his app and it was like I got
kind of jealous and then I got on and
then they started sponsoring the show
which we signed on and you invest in
amazing amazing stock prices don't have
to hold you back you can buy a piece of
a company you love for as low as $1
build your portfolio a little bit at a
time buy one share buy half a share
three and a quarter share it's it's up
to you your budget and your goals your
first stock is on the house when you set
up your account
so
toast robin hood calm to learn more and
claim your free stock I started just
like buying stocks of companies that
like I use and then I felt like I'm
supporting myself you know and yeah
but I think the testing in your interest
yeah you can low you can buy as low as a
dollar so go to toe stop robin hood calm
to learn more claim your free stock it's
a great app you you know gotta start
thinking about the future got to think
about start thinking about retirement
you do so toast robin hood calm
listeners can get started with a free
stock but only by going to toast out
robin hood calm check it out thank you
robin hood for sponsoring this recap of
real houses in new jersey and then like
you can read some biz news about the
storm clouds are coming in it's about to
probably get delayed oh my god i pray
because it's connecting like then i'm
[ __ ] [ __ ] have you ever missed a
connecting flight like the second flight
yes i did torture very sad it was my
fault though shower in the job killer at
the shower it was really a crazy time i
took a shower in the JFK Airport i was
going back to Colgate I was coming from
Las Vegas and I was going straight off
the plane to my formal so I was like
I'll shower at the Sky Lounge and then
do my makeup on the plane and hop off
the plane at syr and head you know to
the strage for what was it called the
rusty rail if you're from upstate New
York like shout out anyways I took a
shower I it was before I learned that
the plane stops boarding ten minutes
before the flight so I figured I would
get there just at the time at the flow
that's a party and I miss my flight like
had a mental breakdown miss formal but I
was in New York so I just went home for
the night and then I was actually it was
the right thing like a God works in
mysterious ways and I didn't need to go
to formal about night and I I didn't
need a night at home okay house in New
Jersey nothing really happened except
Margaret had a beautiful brunch in that
property that she's selling she put like
an outdoor brunch together it was really
beautiful like I was surprised where
someone who keeps talking about like how
she needs to sell the house or any she
put together a real swanky soiree with
drag queens and it was so much fun and
everyone brought their moms is actually
a really sweet idea to celebrate
Mother's Day but she didn't invite
Theresa obviously because they're not
talking she didn't talk to her at the
Fashion Show and she said chose her side
and meet her men now go sleep Theresa
was being insane being so angry that she
wasn't invited and then of course she
has an excuse for everything like how
you can't say anything to her because
her husband's in jail it was really rude
of Margaret not to invite her because
Theresa
her mother and you know how hard this
day is for her and don't get me wrong
it's definitely know what else was a
hard day like when your ponytail was
yanked and you got whiplash ya know it
was just like excuse excuses shoots like
we like I know me and Margaret aren't on
good terms but she should have invited
me because of this like she was so mean
then they all get together at Jackie's
house literally Theresa walked in the
door first thing she says Thank You
Jackie so much for inviting me Margaret
why didn't you invite me because you
took dang else I know it's it's very
crystal clear what did Margaret a the
episode pretty much like ended there and
she was ago we're starting already and
everyone's like oh like it didn't really
turn into anything but it's obviously
gonna be a point of contention the
entire weekend in the Hamptons but the
entitlement like why do you think you
should be married you're fighting like
it was so unfair and you're not even an
inactive fight like you chose your side
like personally as like like me taking
over Margaret's body like I'm done with
Theresa like you don't come to my house
you don't come to my party so it was
like an intimate affair everyone was
like what their mom's talking about
their relationship with their moms it
was actually like a really sweet brunch
and I actually think it would have made
Theresa feel worse on Mother's Day to
see every all of her friends there with
their moms it's not a reason not to it
but that's not the reason no but she had
to spend the day with her kids like it
was you know it worked out perfectly in
my opinion Theresa was there with her
kids they to a lovely brunch for her
they were to required me to cry
beautiful and everyone else got to be
with their moms at Margaret and they had
a great time and a friend of theirs in
Treece is not a friend of Margaret's in
last week's episode there was no reason
why she shouldn't but it's just so clear
to me I'm Jackee invited everyone to the
Hamptons including Dolores and Teresa
and they seem to be getting along
obviously they split up to go in the car
and it was Jackie Margaret Melissa
mm-hmm Teresa Jennifer Dolores and then
in the car Jennifer was telling everyone
what she found on Google which was that
she went south the house for $50,000 a
month in the summer but that's the going
rate for me that is a I couldn't get
over there whoa it's on the beach yes
mmm and actually think on the road it's
between the bay and the beach so you get
both just look what I saw from the drive
oh wow that's premium really nothing
else really happened like more boring
stuff with what's-her-name Delores and
Michael she went to visit him at the
hospital like saying that her mom won't
let her move into the house unless she's
engaged Ike it's just so silly he's just
like that is so silly for a teenager you
know yeah but I just think that that
whole storyline is incredibly boring and
I don't need to Lawrence to get married
I think she's like happy in her
you know and like stop trying to like
make it so that like this more serious
Dolores and Michaels get like the more
Frank needs to like step away and I
don't want that they have a perfect
thing going and Frank being like Dolores
is Real Housewives husband like he goes
with the guys like love like he's gonna
go to the Jersey Shore right he uh he's
also probably gonna be at the reunion
like like he was to the party he's like
he's her like husband he's her work
husband and Michael's her home husband
and like I love that I don't want to see
Michael at Jennifer's birthday no but
what Dolores was saying she's like I
never give him grief for not coming and
stuff like I totally get that he
respects his work and I respect that
completely but he definitely takes
advantage of my kindness because now
he's missing stuff because he wants to
go to Sniper school like that's not work
yeah so she's like he takes advantage
and I would love for him to come to
stuff but actually if he comes does that
mean Frank can't come no but they all
get along but it just it doesn't make
sense why Frank would come anymore like
this isn't a show about this isn't
Vanderpump rules like no and I think
secretly not that Frank is in love with
Dolores but I think he wants them to
stay at that's in this like purgatory
period be so he can still go on TV and
we need him on he just was at that boys
poker night when technically it should
have been Michael right and I love the
boys like I love Bill Aiden so much like
anything we got with him was just so
anyways and he was like I used to go to
the Hamptons all the time when you were
young and beautiful and you still are
that's what he said he like almost said
something offensive he's like and you're
still you know like the bill Aidan just
textbook of how you should change your
behavior from seeing yourself on TV
should be shown to so many people and I
was reading a whole thread about how
this is my housewives to serve two
seasons minimum because some people
didn't really like Jennifer last season
I loved her and I don't think there's
anyone who doesn't love her now no I
agree
she's an LGBTQ icon she's a great mom
she's a funny friend she's hilarious she
gets wasted I think next weekend gets in
the Lissa's face like she has it all she
has it all and maybe if we didn't give
her two seasons like we wouldn't have
seen now this like more intimate side if
we're talking about her family like I
think I think it's okay but if that
applies I mean I would have had to have
two seasons of Peggy so hon Ian okay you
know why like I could see how maybe she
might have been misunderstood I don't
think she was but I could see it okay
this was a one season wonder choice
chard was not right she was - I don't
like
Eden's has soon she's awful came in out
of a tough time but you know what if
you're this is gonna sound so terrible
but it's this is the type of Shelly if
you're very wealthy and have a nice
house like you deserve two seasons you
know what I mean but like Eden says even
at a small house I don't need to seek
new seasons of a small house it's it's
an attainable show
that's right Leeanne Locken like never
really made sense under a Housewives of
Dallas because she's like arguably the
most controversial and like also the
poorest yeah but she brings the most
drama and says like the craziest thing
and is the villain yeah and when
everyone act else is like acting normal
and rational like it doesn't really
create like a hotbed of drama well
that's what we'll see in Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills because it seems like
they're all best friends okay
but then there's affair between Denise
and Brandi like oh and by the way
they're all in New York now and Denise
was not there I didn't realize yeah they
all went to see Erika star the Bruce
like the friendship between Tori and
Erika is just like I feel like these are
my friends and what if they're finally
getting along right now and now like I
need that for Stephanie in camera and I
can't even like talk about it really
like upsets me sometime still both
comment on my photo and I feel like I'm
in the middle of it oh my god yes by the
way I actually just was looking at your
Instagram comments because I was like
damn she has so many verified people
looking at her comments and it was
Stephanie and Cameron maybe I'm the one
who can bring them together we should
have them on the show like a full Judge
Judy moment I know because I really
shocked they're just like not hearing
each other because the I mean now it's
gotten to a point with like the country
club and now they're saying stuff they
can't do it's too far it's getting a
little too messy but the big the crux of
this miss this whole fight is a
misunderstanding on Cameron's behalf and
she refused to acknowledge out at the at
the reunion and I think why you struggle
so much in the situation is because you
like them both but I think you secretly
like want to be Cameron and you can't
relate to her because she's kind of
wrong right but I also want to be
Stephanie like I want to be both of them
equally you know I definitely wanna be
Stephanie like I I love her so much in
her house is so sick and her husband is
so cute so freaky and keep everything
and then her friendship with Brandi and
but I just Oh should we talk about
something you know someone dug up on
Twitter on old tweets of Max from the
new banner pump rules caste and they're
bad like it's the n-word 1000 times like
multiple tweets oh my god yeah so just
thought everyone should know about that
it's like that's so shocking but then
it's also like that's not chalky no but
it's like it's shocking because it's
like you to see this person like you
wouldn't think like in his spare time he
tweets the n-word no when are the tweets
from when he was 19 but what I'm here I
don't know
not that it matters but it's just like
wow yeah another day someone was digging
that up on Twitter it's like if you
and learned at this point you're getting
a little bit of fame just to leave your
Twitter bro like let me be a lesson for
everyone
delete your tweets okay just delete the
whole thing no I don't even need one I
guess I go on the app from the morning
toast oh sometimes so I can't say I
don't use it at all
I like to be on Twitter just like see
what hateful people are saying just to
like see both sides of every story you
know yeah and I do like to see if I'm
watching a show just what the people are
saying but I feel like the people just
watch it and go to sleep and then some
people are just trying to go viral on
Twitter and saying crazy stuff you know
the people watching go to sleep you said
it
okay thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast this was
our last episode of the week if you're
looking for more content we will have a
patron episode coming out tomorrow
Friday but yes tomorrow we have a
general Q&A that we just recorded and
it's really the questions we're really
good we talked a lot about the toast as
a business the news studio just like
family etc then there also won't be
enough so it on Monday because it's
Martin Luther King Day and we have a
patreon episode then of toast radio lots
of new music for you to start 2020
whether you're looking to be inspired
emotionally or physically the theme is
motivational Monday which we each like
took in our own direction as you'll see
yeah and it's just like songs like get
you motivated whether it is to like do
what you have to do to work out like we
are we just want to be here like we're
not super motivational I don't think
that channeled our inner Tony Robbins
for this episode and if we're not going
to salt you and it's an episode that I
look forward to listening to when I'm
feeling just like down and grouchy um so
that's patreon.com slash the morning
trust we've had so many new patrons
thank you guys for joining patreon.com
social morning toast since there won't
be an episode Friday and Monday of the
regular toast there'll be new episodes
coming out on patreon check it out
thank you so much for listening for the
morning toast millennium morning show we
go live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so if you're
watching us on YouTube please feel free
to give this video a thumbs up and
subscribe to us youtube.com slash of the
morning toast and Campos tickets go on
sale on Tuesday we'll talk all about kam
toast on the show on Tuesday we'll do
some Q&A so that if you have any
questions before you buy your ticket we
can hopefully answer them for you we're
also available as a podcast pretty much
anywhere podcasts can be found so that
Spotify iTunes stitcher public radio in
our videocast box all the apps so
wherever you choose to listen to podcast
find us the morning toast subscribe
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are we
love you guys so much of an amazing week
and enjoy your Martin Luther King Day
Off Thank You MLK for the great work you
did thank you